toi le frisé vous allez traîner vos
souliers de princesse jusqu'à la rue
simard est la russie maria numéro 23 au
numéro 23 ya un code passer le code bien
une porte après la portière service du
midi qui passera vos fils est
l'ingrédient de la tu fais ta cuisine
est une livre mon gâteau à ses heures
pétantes s'en faut t'es sûr et va venir
lundi dans une heure il va pas tarder
mon taxi profite du bonheur
tu sais quoi
tu devrais arrêter les pilules way au
[ __ ] je peux parler là et merde aux
dames
grâce aux traces morales avec deux
bouchons de tasdon gosier râler la jouer
fine il savait bien comme gardant je
finirai par chier des preuves
et c'est pas prêt le relâcher d'infos
et puis on sait en cellule pour des
états j'allais les faire courir les
[ __ ] et ils ont pris leurs hommes du
banlieusard
ils ont mis tout le monde à la menthe
qui naviguent rançon draco et mais quand
tout réussi le seul truc qui était
inaccessible c'est évident il il avait
pigé etc latinas faire c'était dans la
coco l'hérault les stups
la machine est devenu tellement
politique que ça a pris une ampleur de
ouf
du coup ces mecs là sont fait respecter
par les plus grands ces mecs là ils
étaient comme nous ils sont partis de
rien et en peu de temps ils sont tous vu
les rois fo qui s'étend faut qu'on soit
plus grand qu on s'attable qu'on domine
quand les knicks tout butin mais dans
quoi maintenant
non non vous finirez par lire ici ou
l'entente de lava une mais qu'il est à
vos soirées personne connaît mais tous
levés invités propre est de la
génération mitterrand toute la panoplie
du pays de candy péter les oreilles et
les narines à techno et à l'électro il
faut c'est clo clo clo je sais à qui
l'on est au milieu on est dans le petit
trafic périphériques
le prêt à taux variable et les mandalas
et ben moi je connais avec dans le
maelström de nous rajouter 100 grammes
de plus tout le monde révèle la même
chose
la tuque la baille la fraîche pour sucer
des tétons toujours plus sucré ces
dictionnaires d'anonymes collard avec un
rêve un énième connard en sommet
géostationnaire sur leur piste poke
hollande
et ensuite